le 19 août 1944 l'avion du majeur angels
est pris en chasse puis abattu par un
escadron nazi dans la forêt de verneuil
sur seine 76 ans après une cinquantaine
de personnes sont présentes pour rendre
hommage à ce soldat américain on est là
pour commémorer à la fois de la
libération de la ville
la mémoire du major et puis
naturellement une l'histoire de france
la grande histoire à travers la petite
puisque c'est aussi l'occasion de
commémorer chaque petit épisode qu'a
connu vernet sur scène durant la grande
guerre les faits de résistance
et puis évidemment l'occupation la
cérémonie s'est déroulée en présence de
jean-claude charbo président de l'union
nationale des combattants
albert pottier président de la
fédération nationale des anciens
combattants d'algérie du maroc et de la
tunisie et de madame la lieutenant
colonel philippe kent a tâché de l'air
adjointe de l'ambassade des états unis
pour nous évidemment c'est un honneur
d'avoir quelqu'un de l'ambassade des
états unis qui tient à cette
commémoration qui montre son attachement
à notre histoire locale et puis à
travers l'histoire locale à notre camp
histoire celle de notre pays
cette cérémonie a lieu tous les ans pour
honorer la mémoire de angels pour la
première fois cette commémoration a été
également celle de la libération de
verneuil-sur-seine un devoir de mémoire
pour alain declerck porte drapeau de la
ville de mourcourt il y en a quand même
beaucoup qui se sont sacrifiés pour que
nous aujourd'hui on existe et qu'on
puisse vivre libres c'est surtout ça qui
est important
la liberté